un mal bouffe risque élevé de temps
or les scientifiques
sans fin
de mardi conseil manger plus tôt pour
éviter certains cancers 3 pour vivre
plus longtemps
buvez du vin il manger du chocolat 4 le
résumé de caréner un protège du cancer
du sein
5 nutri score attention les aliments mal
notés augmente les risques de cancer
six des crucifères bon pour le côlon cet
mardi conseil attention aux noyaux
d'abricot 8 la diète cétogène efficace
quand le cancer
on risque sa vie à ne manger ni pâte ni
pain 10 voici quoi manger pour rallonger
votre espérance de vie de trente ans
alors ça c'est juste une petite
sélection sur septembre 2018 on en
jouera sur ce ne sont pas les dix
commandements
mais ce sont des titres d'articles parus
dans la presse ou sur des sites internet
des titres d'articles qui nous explique
comment bien manger
comment bien manger pour être en bonne
santé pour ne pas tomber malade voire
même pour se guérir
alors il ya les aliments à privilégier
un plus climat anti inflammatoires par
excellence ou mieux
l'avocat pléthore d'articles nous
explique les bonnes raisons le consommer
allié minceur coupe-faim réguler le taux
de sucre
donne de l'énergie et on notera ici que
le bilan carbone de l'avocat que l'on
importe quand même depuis bout du monde
est le cadet de nos soucis c'est bon
pour notre santé
pourquoi se soucier notre planète
peut-être parce que les deux sont un peu
lié un mais bon c'est un autre débat
et puis les éléments qui sont à
proscrire
ceux qui nous font du mal ceux qui font
du mal à nos enfants qui sont assis à
notre table ce qu'ils peuvent
insidieusement le tuer alors dans cette
jolie distincts absolument pas anxiogène
on retrouve la charcuterie des fromages
affinés le sel le sucre un bien d'autres
en somme tout ce qui est bon pour être
en bonne santé
il faut être à 7 voire même rigoriste
être en bonne santé mesdames et
messieurs ça se mérite
si je reprends le cas du sucre qui comme
le sel et sans aucune exagération et en
toute mesure nommées parfois le poison
blanc il est aujourd'hui pointée du
doigt
vilipendé lapider sur la place publique
nommé responsable de bien de nos maux et
surtout de l'un de ceux qui nous fait
plus peur
le cancer et comment ça se construit
comment on désigne le bouc émissaire
comment joue en un ce n'est plus le gras
l'animé le sucre eh bien on se sert des
discours des scientifiques des
trouvailles des chercheurs toujours le
cas du sucre une étude a été publiée en
2015 par une équipe de scientifiques de
failles de philadelphie et cette étude
avait pour conclusion principale que
deux types de sucre favoriserait le
développement de métastases du cancer du
sein chez la souris
je répète chez la souris
alors les accidents le public ne sont
guère embêtés avec ce détail qui pour
l'anecdote est un détail très récurrent
il faut savoir aujourd'hui que de
nombreuses recherches notamment en
nutrition sont réalisés sur des animaux
donne des résultats intéressants mais ne
sont pas réputés chez l'homme pour des
questions méthodologiques difficile à
résoudre
alors je sais vous allez me dire c'est
comme des chercheurs ça ils cherchent et
chargé les fonds publics ont pu ça plus
part du temps mais je ne trouve pas ce
qu'on aimerait qu'ils trouvent
oui je sais mais je vais prendre une
histoire de cancer de sucre et de souris
donc deux types de sucre favoriserait
l'accroissement de métastases du cancer
du sein chez la souris
comment les artic grand public se sont
saisis de ça eh ben on retrouve des
titres plutôt interrogeant puisqu'on a
le sucre pourrait augmenter le cancer du
sein
donc on a quand même ici l'emploi du
conditionnel et un article publié sur un
site internet de très grandes audiences
qui se réfère à cette recherche il la
nomme titre ainsi comment le sucre agit
sur le cancer du sein d'envoyer un sa
peine travestie à peine modifié
imagina sur sa aucune conséquence sur
lecteur le consommateur ou même le
malade supprimer le sucre et vous
pourrez vous prévenir du cancer
supprimer le sucre il pourrait peut-être
même guérir du cancer mais on oublie ici
que le cancer armand lié à une seule
cause un seul comportement qu'il est
multifactoriel tous ces artistes grand
public qui nous explique ce qu'il faut
consommer pour être en bonne santé nous
parle de la maladie comme une
responsabilité individuelle site un
cancer ce qu'à un moment donné que tu as
quand même bien venu chercher un attends
tu bu un verre de vin par jour n'a
jamais fait footing du temps par un
carré de chocolat dans tout cas fait à
temps mais t'as jamais mangé de lucifer
je savais pertinemment que c'était bon
pour ton colons
tu manges et du tout saucisson avec ton
pastis lors des apéros d'été faut pas se
plaindre pas se plaindre
c'est tellement plus simple de dire les
choses ainsi
car on évacue tout ce qui est lié à une
question et une responsabilité politique
publique collective par exemple nos
modes de production leurs effets sur
l'environnement et donc sur notre santé
mais attendez en vue - doute ce à dire
qu'ils auraient un lien entre
comportement alimentaire environnement
et santé
mais alors l'avocat est il vraiment bon
faut que je demande à mon coach de vie
j'espère que lui il sera parce que cette
histoire de responsabilité individuelle
est un levier qui marche très bien qui
fait écho en nous car très centrés sur
nous mêmes sur le développement
personnel sous notre bien-être
autocentré on cherche à se préserver par
tous les moyens possibles rappel bulls
man dans son livre très médiatisé
dernièrement les enfants du vide le dit
très bien nous sommes dans une société
individualiste une société de solitude
alors bien sûr c'est rassurant de se
dire qu'on peut soi-même activer des
leviers personnel pour être en bonne
santé se préserver mais n'oublions pas
notre sens commun n'oublions pas notre
sens critique
il s'agit de ne pas écouter n'importe
quoi ni n'importe qui car ils sont
nombreux aujourd'hui un des experts en
tout genre à nous parler de notre
alimentation
alors il ya et scientifiques bien sûr
mais aussi les chefs il ya les médecins
les nutritionnistes diététiciens les
coachs et également les journalistes les
industriels de l'agroalimentaire les
youtuber les influenceurs les blogueurs
mais qui sont les vrais experts
peut-être ceux qui n'ont pas de conflit
d'intérêts peut-être sedan ce n'est pas
le fond de commerce de nous faire
consommer tel produit ou tel service
peut-être ce qui se réfère à une ou
plusieurs études dont on peut trouver la
source
mais je sais c'est pas simple de
demeurer ici le vrai du faux
mais soyons attentifs le super aliments
et bien sûr attractif car facile à
identifier
mais une alimentation à base de baies
rouges de grenade d'ail d'oignons de
judor de thé vert ne fera pas de
miracles l'alimentation prodigieuse à
base d'un ou plusieurs aliments est un
leurre et fondent notre modèle
alimentaire le réduit à un modèle
égoïste et individualiste
pourtant on a encore les champions du
monde du temps passé à table
notre modèle est avant tout conviviale
l'alimentation
c'est bien plus qu'un simple moyen que
d'être en bonne santé alors bien sûr
qu'il faut considérer bien à manger ce
qui est bien pour soi bien pour son
corps bien pour sa santé mais il faut
aussi penser le bon à manger ce qui est
bien pour nos relations
bon goût bon pour l'environnement
l'alimentation miracle n'existe pas mais
nous avons mieux à portée de main nous
avons une alimentation saine équitable
convivial collégiale ne la série fions
pas au profit d'une vision est concentré
et simpliste notre alimentation
mais au contraire chéri sont là et
cultivons là pour l'avenir